-Bonjour, Aurélien !
-Comment ça va ?
-Hé, Cathy ! Cathy !
Donc, ce monsieur
que tu vois, en face,
il était venu
en voisin,
pour l'inauguration !
-Exactement.
Il y a combien de temps ?
-Ca fait plus de...
-Ca fait... Trois ans.
-Oui.
-Trois ou quatre ans.
Même plus que ça,
peut-être.
Ca va faire quasiment cinq ans.
-C'est vrai.
-Mais comme on vieillit pas,
ça se voit pas.
-Oh non !
-Bonjour.
Je suis Aurélien Pradié,
*député de la 1re circonscription
du Lot.
Un de mes combats depuis mon arrivée
à l'Assemblée est l'inclusion
des personnes en situation
de handicap dans la société.
-Dans sa circonscription du Lot,
autour de Cahors,
la lutte pour l'inclusion des
personnes handicapées
doit être mise en oeuvre
dès le plus jeune âge,
selon Aurélien Pradié.
Pour savoir comment,
le député LR a tenu à nous montrer
l'école maternelle de Catus,
un modèle du genre.
-Bonjour.
-Monsieur le directeur.
Ca va ?
-Oui, et vous ?
-Monsieur le maire.
-Vous allez bien ?
-Oui ! Et vous-même ?
-Très bien !
Content de vous voir. Ca va ?
-Oui, très bien, et vous ?
-Au milieu
de la cinquantaine d'élèves,
certains petits sont un peu
différents des autres :
ce sont des enfants autistes.
Une unité spécialisée
a été créée pour eux.
-Tout le monde est
en récréation
au même moment ?
-Oui.
-Vous avez combien d'enfants
dans l'unité ?
-Sept.
Le cahier des charges, c'est sept.
A Catus, j'en ai sept.
On va être
sur de l'intervention précoce,
de 3 à 6 ans,
pour les enfants,
sur de l'accompagnement intensif :
car on est sur 24h d'accompagnement
par semaine.
Chaque temps est pensé
sur des objectifs bien précis.
La récréation est un objectif :
de travailler
les interactions
avec ses pairs,
travailler la gestion
des émotions...
-Mais il n'existe
que 2000 places
d'un tel dispositif, en France,
quand 10 fois plus d'enfants,
de trois à six ans ont été
diagnostiqués autistes.
-Ca veut dire
que les enfants autistes sont pris
en charge comment, en France ?
-Pas scolarisés,
ou très peu.
Ils vont faire
une demi-journée par semaine,
glorieusement,
quand on veut bien la donner,
et le reste du temps,
à la maison, ou en structure,
hors du milieu ordinaire.
-En fait,
40 % des enfants autistes
n'ont accès à presque aucune forme
de scolarisation.
Pourtant, les progrès permis
par ces unités
sont gigantesques.
Prenez Amine :
il est arrivé ici il y a deux ans,
sans savoir parler,
et avec de gros retards
pour son âge.
-Toi, il a séché.
-Désormais, il a autant
de compétences que les autres.
Pour cause : il passe
une grande partie de son temps
hors de son unité spécialisée,
mais dans une classe
de grande section classique.
Seule différence :
Leomara Pinto,
la psychologue de l'école,
l'accompagne,
pour l'aider à progresser.
Brouhaha
Musique douce
-C'est bien, Amine.
Regarde, maintenant.
"Le petit".
"Le petit", tu as écrit.
Là, ensuite, c'est...
Le mot "Cochon".
-Et là, il y a "dinde" ?
-Oui ! c'est très bien.
C'est là que tu mets.
-Ah oui ! Il est là.
-Oui.
Ca, il est là,
et tu as déjà fait.
-Résultat : Amine va pouvoir
intégrer un CP classique,
l'année prochaine.
Mais pour sept élèves autistes,
il faut cinq adultes en plus
dans l'école. Une prise en charge
qui coûte 25 000 euros par an
pour chaque enfant accueilli,
et qui est trop rare.
-C'est une question de moyens.
On met des budgets significatifs,
mais avec des résultats
qui sont exceptionnels.
Des enfants accompagnés
dès le début,
ce sont des problèmes
qu'on n'a pas à gérer
avec une telle ampleur, après.
Les économies de bouts de chandelle
que l'on fait
où on pourrait intervenir,
on les reprend en pleine figure,
quelques années après.
-Mais ouvrir des classes
d'enseignement spécialisé est
un parcours du combattant.
Leur nombre a décidé
au niveau national,
et les territoires
se font une concurrence accrue
pour les accueillir.
A. Pradié en sait quelque chose :
il est en plein dedans
pour une école élémentaire,
dans son fief de Labastide-Murat,
la commune où il a grandi.
Une enfance bouleversée,
et qui explique
peut-être un peu
son engagement actuel.
-Le handicap,
il a frappé ma famille, et mon père,
quand j'étais très jeune.
Il a changé notre vie.
On m'aurait dit
que je m'occuperais du handicap
en faisant de la politique...
J'aurais sûrement
parié que non,
car c'était tellement
présent dans ma vie
que j'avais peut-être pas envie
d'en faire davantage.
En fait, vous êtes un peu rattrapé
toujours par ça,
et je ne crois pas qu'on fasse
de la politique par hasard.
-Après des mois de tractations,
c'est son ancienne école
qui a été désignée
pour ouvrir une classe accueillant
des élèves autistes,
à partir de six ans.
-Monsieur, moi, c'est Louis.
-Je t'ai reconnu.
-Son cousin !
Mais comme vous êtes quelques-uns
à avoir bien grandi...
-Ca pousse.
-Oui.
Six mois sans vous voir,
ça fait bizarre.
Donc, la salle
qu'on est censés utiliser,
pour accueillir les enfants.
Après l'avoir rénovée.
Il y a tout à faire :
repeindre,
adapter, remeubler...
L'avantage,
c'est qu'ils sont
au milieu
de tout le monde,
On les met pas
dans un endroit isolé,
ils sont vraiment
dans la vie de l'école.
Mais il y a
un peu de boulot.
-Il a bien fallu toute son énergie
de député pour convaincre
à la fois l'Education nationale,
mais aussi les autorités de santé,
que l'équipe enseignante
était, ici,
extrêmement motivée
pour tenter l'expérience.
Mais à quelques mois de l'ouverture,
rien n'est encore gagné.
-Ca a pris des années de bataille.
Donc, une bonne nouvelle.
On aura cette unité ici.
Maintenant, on va être
sur la mise en oeuvre,
ce qui est aussi compliqué :
comme les décisions viennent
d'endroits différents,
les infos aussi.
Donc, on croise nos informations,
entre ce qu'a décidé l'ARS,
l'Education nationale...
-Bonjour !
Brouhaha
-Pour accueillir trois enfants
autistes en janvier,
il va falloir encore trouver
un enseignant spécialisé
et c'est encore la pénurie.
-Ce qui m'inquiète,
c'est le recrutement
de l'enseignant spécialisé
parce qu'à Catus, il m'a expliqué
qu'ils avaient eu l'enseignant
dès le mouvement de la rentrée.
-Le manque de personnel,
un problème criant
chez les AESH, ces accompagnants
d'élèves en situation de handicap
exerçant
en milieux ordinaires
pour tous les enfants
handicapés.
On en compte 125 000 alors que
430 000 seraient nécessaires,
mais impossible
d'en embaucher davantage.
Aurélien Pradié,
qui les reçoit ce jour-là,
sait bien pourquoi.
-Bon, bienvenue.
Certaines connaissent le bureau.
L'idée, c'est qu'on parle
du concret,
comment la rentrée se passe
depuis début septembre dans le Lot.
-Moi, je travaille
pour quatre enfants en même temps,
avec des technologies
différentes, et là,
il faut s'adapter.
-Et les parcours de vie,
on voit de plus en plus
d'enfants autistes, HPI,
donc il y a une reconnaissance,
mais bon,
c'est pas une école inclusive
parce qu'il n'y a pas ce qu'il faut
derrière,
donc c'est une aberration.
-Il y en a plein qui disent
qu'ils ne tiendront pas le rythme
à ce niveau-là.
-C'est pas un esclave.
-Pour 24 heures,
je m'en cache pas,
c'est 897 euros
et quelques centimes.
On n'est pas aux 900.
-Le problème, je pense,
des AESH,
c'est qu'aujourd'hui,
elles n'aient pas
un statut reconnu.
Tant qu'elles ne seront pas
fonctionnaires d'Etat,
ce sera le bazar.
Elles n'ont pas de fiche de poste,
elles n'ont pas d'autre couverture
que celle qu'on connaît.
C'est trop précaire.
Elles n'ont rien,
elles n'ont rien et en plus,
il manque les formations,
il manque tout.
-Le député compte déposer
une proposition de loi
pour améliorer
le statut et le salaire
des AESH...
et il pense avoir gain de cause
cette fois,
contrairement
à ce qui s'est passé
lors de sa dernière tentative.
-En 2019,
je n'ai pas de problème,
tout le monde était d'accord
pour voter le texte,
de François Ruffin en passant
par le Rassemblement National,
les seuls qui ont bloqué
étaient ceux...
Les élus
d'Emmanuel Macron,
c'est un élément factuel,
mais en 2019, le scandale politique,
il vient de là. C'est que
le texte n'a pas été rejeté,
simplement, la majorité a fait
une motion de rejet préalable
pour qu'on ne l'examine pas.
Ils se sont pris
une volée de bois vert.
Aujourd'hui, s'il y a un vote,
je connais le résultat
parce que ceux
qui l'avaient bloqué en 2019
sont moins nombreux.
Voilà,
c'est tout.
Il rit.
-Des batailles à l'Assemblée,
il en a déjà gagné,
notamment celle
de la déconjugalisation
de l'allocation adultes handicapés,
ce qui a permis aux personnes
de ne plus voir
leur aide réduite
quand elles sont en couple,
un enjeu car 20 % des handicapés
vivent
sous le seuil de pauvreté.
Musique douce
Autre moyen d'en finir
avec la précarité :
l'emploi. Aurélien Pradié
connaît bien
cet ESAT de Cahors,
une entreprise
adaptée pour les personnes
handicapés
qui donne du travail
à 45 salariés.
...
-Ca, c'est un atelier
parmi nos cinq ateliers.
-Ca va ?
-Ca va.
-Oui, tout va bien ? Bon...
C'est vous qui êtes
à la paperasse ?
-Euh ben oui,
on avance... Enfin...
On peut faire les chemises,
on peut faire les mouillages...
Mais sinon, je fais aussi un peu
d'essorage. Je fais les deux.
-Vous faites les deux ?
-Je fais les deux.
-Ici, tout est fait
pour adapter les tâches
aux possibilités des gens
et les faire travailler
à leur rythme...
...mais depuis quelque temps,
ces ESAT doivent accueillir
d'autres types de publics.
-On a de plus en plus de personnes
du milieu ordinaire
qui échouent
dans le milieu ordinaire
et qui sont réorientées
vers le milieu protégé.
-C'est le cas de six personnes
récemment embauchées ici.
Très révélateur, selon le député,
du manque de prévention
au sein des entreprises.
-On a un monde du travail
de plus en plus brutal
pour lequel des profils
plus fragiles
ont de plus en plus de mal
à résister
et souvent, le milieu ordinaire
les éjecte,
on va dire les choses,
sauf que les ESAT,
historiquement, ont été conçus
pour des travailleurs handicapés,
des handicaps lourds,
des handicaps qu'on connaissait,
pas les handicaps psychiques
tels qu'on les connaît
aujourd'hui.
Ils arrivent dans un environnement
qui n'est pas fait pour eux.
Après, il y a
un vrai débat.
Est-ce que ça veut dire qu'il faut
à 100 % faire évoluer
le milieu protégé
pour qu'il accueille
tous ceux que le monde du travail
ne peut pas accueillir
ou est-ce qu'il ne faut pas aussi
travailler sur le monde du travail
pour qu'il soit capable
lui-même de conserver,
peut-être
de moins abîmer ?
C'est aussi une question.
-Le député du Lot
a fait du handicap son cheval
de bataille parce qu'il veut
d'une droite
solidaire et sociale,
parfois à contre-courant
du parti.
-Je viens presque une fois par an.
-Oui.
-Voir si vous avez pas
vieilli.
Elle rit.
-Oui.
-Il faut le blanc à part
et les couleurs à part.
Rouge clair et rouge foncé,
on le met dans une corbeille.
On le met à part.
Pareil pour le mouillage.
-C'est comme en politique,
il faut pas mélanger les couleurs.
Sinon, ça fait
les mauvaises couleurs.
-Depuis la loi handicap de 2005,
les politiques en faveur
des personnes handicapées
se sont multipliées.
Pourtant, les objectifs
définis par le texte
sont encore loin
d'être tous atteints.
Musique douce
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA